Kim Kardashian is keeping it sexy for  date night I want to wear things that  make me feel good about myself  the reality star hit the town with her  husband Kanye West to grab dinner in LA  Saturday night Kim K kept things casual  in an eye-popping ensemble flashing  major cleavage in a black bodysuit a  matching floral and coat and high waist  ripped jeans while Kanye stayed close by  his wife in a coordinating black  sweatshirt I love that 36 year old Kim  was spotted stepping out with her  signature slicked back low bun with a  middle part she recently debuted a sleek  shoulder length haircut at the daily  front row fashion Los Angeles Awards  they feel confident and I'm very happy  [Music]